if you're struggling with flights you
may think about driving that's not
necessarily an easier road especially
with the weather and we have mary jane
baliza explaining
it's a nationwide problem too as many
people are trying to find a way home
after flight cancellations due to the
weather and coveted surge we originally
rented a ford explorer but they're not
that great in the snow and we know that
there's a lot of snow up there right now
because we're going to zion
so
we actually rented a minivan because my
husband said that would do better in the
snow so we thought we'll rent a car and
go to las vegas lots of flights out of
las vegas
okay so that flight got canceled today
rob williamson runs a car rental company
on sahara and decatur the demand is
getting bigger than supply she came to
us to rent a car so she could drive back
to seattle and they were waiting for a
call from the mother to see if the
mother had actually taken off and with
so many calls and online bookings
williamson says they are out of suvs
it's probably less than 30 percent of
our entire fleet williamson has other
vehicles for now but may have to put the
brakes on soon it's difficult in a city
like las vegas when we have new year's
coming up to send our fleet to different
cities because we do have this fleet
utilized utilized 100 percent here in
the city for this weekend williamson
says he expects 90 percent of his
inventory to be booked through the new
year so he says it's best to book a car
in advance if you can reporting at reed
international airport mary jane vallieza
live local now